[Music]
all right we're gonna go to joseph in
springfield missouri hey joseph how are
you
good hey christy here rachel how are you
guys great what's going on
hey got a money question all right
um so my wife and i are trying to figure
out what to do uh we got we have thirty
thousand dollars in our savings account
okay we have uh 25 000 of student loans
we did buy a house almost a year ago
that needed some um renovation and
remodel so we have about twenty thousand
i'd say that until we are kind of done
with the house where we're you know
happy and comfortable
um and we've been on one car for five
months and um that time has ended we
definitely need to get a second car so
just kind of want your opinion your
advice on kind of what to tackle first
and then maybe kind of how much in each
category to prioritize yeah absolutely
uh joseph how much do you guys make a
year
um our monthly budgetable incomes about
4 500. okay
um 55 to 60s to take home yeah what are
these improvements because because i
understand some improvements are
necessary when you move in a house if
it's like mold or something major but
you said happy and comfortable joseph
tell me about these improvements are
these are these optional joseph be
honest with me
yeah some are needed uh you know uh tubs
faucets leaking stuff like that need
bathroom remodels some are you know we'd
like to um
updated fixtures in the kitchen and
stuff so we know that sun is absolutely
like yep we need to do it and some is
like
well
if it's instagram worthy you know we'll
get there eventually um but uh yeah like
remodeling the bathrooms fixing leaky
tubs putting on doors and putting new
floors in picking out the moldy carpet
and stuff like that have you all
calculated the amount of things that are
like really necessary like moldy carpet
and then kind of itemize like two
separate lists like things we must do
now to live here and things that would
be nice to do later when we have the
cash
yeah it's about i would say it's about
10
um of those 20 that we calculated half
of that is like okay we really need to
do this and then the other half is like
these are some things coming up in the
future that we want to do and we kind of
like having that security of the extra
you know ten thousand sitting there for
those things gotcha yeah
okay well what and uh i'm sorry i'm
gonna ask about the car situation so you
guys have been doing it for five months
how did you do it for five months and
why suddenly is that season over
um well i am an educator so back to
schools around the season um i'm also a
a sports official and so i have to
travel for games and stuff
um and so
that since both of those things are
coming back up the for the fall semester
it's uh we can't we can't juggle it with
just one vehicle yep okay
so where you guys are at because of the
house repairs because of the debt that
you guys still have
uh the good thing is you have thirty
thousand dollars in savings so from that
we're gonna kind of just split that
we're gonna categorize that thirty
thousand are you ready
yeah i'm ready i would spit i mean i
would spend nothing on a car right now
nothing five grand maybe i mean get a
cheap cheap cheap cheap cheap cheap
cheap old car uh something that's
reliable obviously we don't wanna
braking all the time but i mean like
just go like go find an old honda civic
and a core do just a old nice car that
is reliable okay nothing big nothing
fancy
um you're 10k i'm going to press you on
it just because i could just hear in
your tone
i'm going to say do it in 5k okay so
that's 10 000 of the 30 that we've
already spent 5k in house stuff of
absolutely needing it and this is
pricing out
different options
different vendors don't just take the
one guy that you hear i mean this is
kind of like this is gonna be bare bones
for just this for a little bit
so i would i would find the things you
absolutely have to do and do it as
inexpensively as possible to get it done
so again i'm gonna cut your ten and five
just for fun
uh so that's 20 grand left you guys have
25 000 student loans i'd keep a thousand
i throw everything else
at the student loans
um
and then you guys are are close at that
point then
to
getting out of debt i mean you're to be
you're going about 6 000 left on those
student loans and i want you guys
gazelle intense at that point i need
something in you joseph
that feels committed okay like i need
you to say i'm done it doesn't feel like
you're super sick and tired of the loans
kind of like they're there i got this
this and this like
if it's gonna if it's gonna leave it's
gotta leave and the sooner you guys
clean this up you get you get rid of it
you get some actual cash as an emergency
fund so when when repairs are needed for
the house that you actually need you
have that cash to pull out and then
from there you can say okay we have our
fully funded emergency fund after you
pay off your debts then we can look to
say okay now do we step up in car
now do we go and look at the house and
do the things that we want to do
more than just the repairs but i mean i
want you guys to go bare bones because
the more you sacrifice your lifestyle
the more
cheap of a car you get the more
uh you price out these home repairs and
you do what's absolutely necessary and
the more money you can throw at the
student loan the faster you guys are
going to clean this up and you're going
to be in such a different
position financially if you do this and
you're going to make your money go so
much further if you're if you do what
rachel says like you've got 30 000 you
look at that like oh wow that's so much
money which is great that you have it
you guys have done well to save that up
but i want you to make i want you to
pinch every penny out of it not just go
oh well we can just do 20 000 of home
repairs and then just you know hang out
and let these student loans hang around
if you do what she's saying and you
really put off those home repairs those
light fixtures all the things even the
ugly bathroom you keep that ugly tile in
there you don't have to remodel the
whole bathroom and gut it to fix a leak
just fix the leak and i know it's
tempting to justify in your mind and go
oh but if we're gonna do it let's do it
at the same time i hear you i hear you i
have that voice in my head too home
repair girl but listen you don't have
the money to do that that would be nice
if you had the money to do that because
you have this debt you actually don't
have the money to gut the bathroom and
do all the nice to haves at the same
time
so what you're going to do is you're
going to make that money go as far as as
you possibly can like rachel said and
you're only going to do the home repairs
that you must do
from a health safety
type of standpoint in order to live in
the house even if that bathroom is ugly
that's right just until
you get your student loans and debt paid
off and here's the thing let that ugly
bathroom motivate you you walk in there
you see the lime green tile you're like
this is why we're paying off our student
loans this is why we're doing this
and joseph what's hard what we just
outlined for you
it's again it's easier said than done
because now emotionally you and your
wife both have to say oh no but we moved
into this house knowing we'd have to do
repairs and we're going to do repairs in
x y and z time and we just pushed your
timeline by about eight months
so it's a hard reality pill to swallow
because your expectations are now
changing um but i would rather you guys
be and i have no debts you're not paying
more interest on the student loans all
that like you're you're out of debt you
actually have cash in the bank so this
home can be a blessing rather than a
curse
and then you wrap back around and say
okay now let's let's fix what we need to
fix and what we want to that and that's
that's being an adult right dave says
all the time adults devise a plan and
fall children do it feels good it feels
good to get the new bathroom yeah it
feels good to do the repairs
on things that are just cosmetic but
hold off and it's what we were just
talking about it's a season it's a
season of sacrifice we're not saying
have an ugly bathroom forever we're not
saying drive a terrible car forever
we're just saying it's a season while
you're going to prioritize this debt
that's dragging you down and stealing
your income
so that once it's gone you can do all
the home repairs you want to that you
save up for in cash you can get a nicer
car that you save up for cash that has
no
payment
dragging behind it and you will
experience that car that bathroom
whatever completely differently when
there's not all this debt attached to it
and that's what we're trying to help you
do short term it is a sacrifice but it's
a short-term sacrifice for a season and
just know this is our why at the end of
this we're gonna save up and do awesome
home repairs that we're gonna be really
proud of and they're paid for in cash